Republican presidential candidate
and former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie.
So yesterday,
Governor, when you announced
that you were running for president,
you called Trump a former friend
a, quote, lonely, self
consumed, self-serving mirror hog.
You've been rather
unsparing in your criticism.
We should note that
you might have people out there
who are skeptical of this
because when you dropped out in 2016,
you endorsed him
or you ran
his transition, you helped
coach him for debates.
What do you say to people
who say, you know,
this guy has always been this way.
You just enabled him
and now you're changing your mind?
Well, look,
you know, back in 20, 16,
Jake was clear to me
he was going to be the nominee.
I had a long relationship with him
at that time, over 15 years,
and I felt
I could help to make him
a better candidate and a better president
if he won.
And I didn't
want Hillary Clinton to be president.
And that's why I ran the first place.
Turns out I was wrong.
I couldn't make him a better candidate
and I couldn't make him
a better president.
And he disappointed me.
And he disappointed
a lot of people in my party.
And a whole lot of people
in this country.
By the way, he performed
and for me,
the breaking point was election night.
20, 20
when he's out there
at two 30 in the morning
claiming the election was stolen
when I knew
he had no evidence to prove that.
And when you want to cut democracy
in that way, you have forfeited
the trust, in my view,
to hold that office
that he's now trying to regain.
And so, yeah,
I did all those things that I and
I make no apologies for them.
But when I make a misjudgment,
I'll admit it.
And I thought I could make him better
And then when I was up, I couldn't.
In fact, he was much worse.
So Trump
last night in response to you running,
ran a rather mocking
video on social media.
There it is.
It's it's you.
I guess he's he's
making fun of your weight.
That's
his we're going to be small
That's his response.
What did you make of that?
What was your response to that?
You know what I saw, Jake?
I just renewed in my own mind
what a child he is.
He's a baby.
Whenever you want to criticize him.
I mean, anyway,
that's the way he responds.
And you and I
are both lucky enough to be parents
and if we had a child
who conducted themselves like that,
we'd send them to the room,
not to the White House. Yeah.
And I think character is destiny
for this country.
And we've got to make a decision
about what
the character of the person should be.
Who sits behind the desk
in the Oval Office.
And if they're going to do that,
kind of stuff.
I mean, it doesn't it's.
It's so childish.
It's so juvenile.
He is such a spoiled baby that,
you know,
beyond that,
what he even say about
something like that, that's ridiculous.
You know, I
if we want to break news here today,
I struggle with my weight
for about 20 years.
Like tens of millions of Americans.
The devil you said. Right. Exactly.
So he's breaking news there.
He keeps telling people something
they don't know.
In the end, for me,
it's about how you perform as a person.
Yeah.
What kind of heart you have.
And I'll put mine up against his
any day in the week.
So on the subject of you
admitting mistakes,
you were pretty candid last night
about some of those mistakes
in your speech last night.
I don't have time to play the excerpt,
but one of the
you talked
you talked about the Bridgegate scandal.
Right.
And trusting people
you should have trusted
and also sending it.
Do you admit setting a tone
that those people thought that
that would be something
that you would find acceptable?
No, I didn't admit that, Jake.
And I'm asking if you know, I don't.